if you're a millennial or gen Zed
Miranda Kerr is likely a household name
and if you weren't familiar with her
before you probably are now
getting confidential went viral so what
do we do with problematic diets we make
them unproblematic so join me as we
transform a slew of detoxing beverages
into a day of balanced meals and if you
are new here please subscribe and hit
that follow button on Instagram and Tick
Tock at Abby's kitchen so long before we
had Tick Tock and YouTube we had Sudoku
and my sister and I would play for hours
on our old purple iMac some habits die
hard but what doku is like Sudoku but
with wood get it
which makes it so much better so you
basically arrange the wooden blocks to
form a line which clears titles from the
board to earn points it is strangely
calming and addictive and honestly
you'll never get bored there are
hundreds of levels and three different
modes to test your speed and your brain
but I love it because I can play
anywhere at any time and I can compete
with my own previous best scores and
best of all it is completely free to
download on both IOS and Android devices
so if you need a new Zen game you can
download
udoku from my link in the description it
really does help my channel when you use
this link so get to it and then tell me
what you think get your diet culture
Bingo cards ready
because this is quite the morning
routine cup in the morning I have
um like 32 ounces of room temperature
water one lemon squeezed in that like
flushes everything out then I have 32
ounces of cold pressed celery juice I
have this um equal medium smoothie heavy
metal detox smoothie oh my God we have
to drink all of that before we can get
to the coffee and food okay Abby
I'm gonna go get some ingredients can
you like unpack this so I guess flushes
everything out is kind of the cute way
to say poop and pee because this legit
is just like a long list of laxatives
and diuretics all water helps you
naturally detox and it's unlikely that
the vitamin C in a squeeze of lemon is
going to have any additional remarkable
benefits for moving your bowels beyond
that of just any water celery juice is
also water and does nothing to alkalize
your body because if it did our girl
Miranda would be dead you know I like it
still gotta kill you if it does speed up
he detox it's because it's one of the
most aggressive sources of fodmaps which
can irritate the gut and give you the
Reds as for the heavy metal detox Like
For the Love of All That is Holy why are
we still taking nutrition advice from a
psychic to this ancient read me fire
there's loads of great nutrition here so
if she enjoys this combo great but
there's no evidence that any of these
ingredients can pull heavy metals out of
your body the only theoretical
explanation that I can come up with for
this bizarre combination is that the
dietary fiber from ingredients like
blueberries can Aid in heavy metal
chelation and cilantro and spirulina has
some animal research for it on the same
purpose but the one human study that I
did find found that cilantro was not
more effective than a placebo in
increasing heavy metal excretion so
bottom line no need to muck up a good
tasting blueberry banana smoothie by
making it taste like fish and soap do we
see a theme here there's like 10 cups of
fluid right right here likely more than
most women need even in a whole day plus
a lot of fiber and fodmaps that taken
together will make you poop but I feel
like there are a lot more tasty and
enjoyable ways to do it yeah if I had to
start every day with that song and dance
I probably would never get out of bed
but since this flute breakfast is all
we're getting today we better make it
count so I'm gonna do my version of
medical medium smoothie without the
and made for a lot less I
thought I was getting a good deal
because the uh on on Loblaws like on the
app this was like 4.99 and I didn't
realize it's the smallest package of
life so that explains it we got wild
blueberries banana plus some frozen
spinach in place of the barley grass
spirulina and herbs then I've got some
nice five percent Greek yogurt for
iodine instead of seaweed because yeah I
just can't wrap my head around seaweed
in a smoothie that's also going to
provide some protein which is what the
medical medium smoothie was sorely
lacking then I've got a here because we
need some fat
plus some extra fiber then I've got some
pea base protein milk for some extra
protein wish me luck on blending this up
I definitely filled this right to the
top
she is thick avocado just always takes
the texture of a smoothie up a notch
straw is too skinny
much better all right we got some
breakfast in let's move our body at a
minimum an hour walk so you do a walk
with the family or you do a walk on the
treadmill all these sound like amazing
options to me but I figure if we want to
truly work out like a Victoria's Secret
model we gotta look like one some angels
allegedly train years to get their wings
and I just kind of found these in my
kids costume bin but they work let's do
it
foreign
all right we moved our body let's talk
about lunch you know for someone
apparently so interested slash obsessed
with health there really isn't a lot of
protein here like Miranda's breakfast
drinks all together plus this lunch both
contain around nine grams of protein
each which just doesn't seem like enough
for an active woman doing like an hour
of walking plus a Tracy Anderson class
so Abby million dollar question how much
protein do we really need as usual it's
complicated because everyone's needs are
unique but we do know that getting a
solid amount of protein in the morning
is ideal for body composition and weight
management as is spacing out protein
throughout the day so the body can only
utilize about 0.4 grams per kilogram per
meal across four or more meals for
muscle protein synthesis that doesn't
mean that the rest of the protein just
goes to waste like protein is King of
the satiety hierarchy so if you're
trying to manage body weight or body
composition as I assume most models are
expected to do it's advantageous to get
at least
0.14 grams per pound of protein per meal
for a daily amount of 0.7 to 1 grams of
protein per pound of body weight that
means if you're 125 pounds you should
aim for around 90 to 125 grams of
protein based on what we've seen so far
I think it'd be very hard for Miranda to
meet those numbers if she wasn't going
to have like a massive heavy protein
meal I thought so let's see how we can
pump this up at least to support my
needs throw a little bit of avocado oil
down some chopped sweet potatoes
a little bit of salt a little bit of
pepper
great source of fiber plus vitamin A
we're going to add in some black beans
for some extra iron
protein and fiber plus a bell pepper for
antioxidants and fiber
[Music]
got a little taco seasoning
some
nutritional yeast
more protein vitamin B12 and
I think it's about time we can add our
Eggies so we part the Red Sea a little
Spritz in the middle and my little trick
is to do
two whole eggs
please don't break
[Music]
and then like fill in the Gap with a
little more egg whites just to add a
little bit more protein salt I got a
fever and the only
needs more cheese well it needs some
cheese so let's do it
melt a little bit of that on there buddy
looks amazing fiber protein and healthy
fats with a little guac I added there
and it makes a very generous portion now
to get a little everything
the cheese that was key breakfast lunch
or dinner this hits
all right folks snack time then I had
right before I came here is just like
cauliflower like cauliflower rice but
it's just cauliflower with green beans
on top and a little bit of um onion you
know I really try hard not to yuck
someone else's yum but just
just see based on my preferences I would
feel like really sad and disappointed if
I was craving a snack and cauliflower
rice with just some green beans and
green onions on top was what was on the
menu so I'm gonna treat this as a mini
meal even though I'm actually not super
hungry but I'm gonna put it together
have the amount I'm craving and then
probably give my kiddos the rest let's
do it okay this is what we call a
hodgepodge mini meal snack I've got a
little bit of leftover white rice which
I'm going to reheat Emily Mariko style
if you know you know I've got a little
bit of kind of meal prepped veggies I
have some roasted bell peppers some
carrots like I said this is random this
is what I have in the fridge and it
sounds like that's kind of also how
Miranda does it so I'm gonna throw in
some edamame a little bit of protein and
fiber and I've got some leftover chicken
as well a couple little pieces probably
more than enough
little teriyaki
secret ingredient a piece of ice and
then
we just kind of wrap her up and pop it
in the microwave until that Rice gets
nice and fluffy and revived all right
heat it through ready to go top a little
bit of sesame seeds for some healthy
fats now that's a snack I think it's
really important that we dissociate the
word snack with just like treats or
highly processed foods because a snack
to me is just a mini meal that's
relatively convenient and this right
here totally ticks the boxes
hmm amazing alrighty folks let's talk
about dinner I normally eat like an
early dinner with the kids
um and I'll have like a soup like a kind
of like like lighter in the evening like
a soup and sometimes like grilled fish
not to be like a food snob but it does
seem like a strange combination to have
just like soup and fish a dinner and
nothing else like there's nothing wrong
with it it just like doesn't work in my
head as a meal right like it's weird
like it's fine but there's just
something missing there that makes it
feel like a proper meal like to just
have a piece of tiny fish on your plate
all by itself something's lacking like
at least let's put a vegetable in there
so I thought why not put these things
together and do a really delicious
Mediterranean fish stew so let's cozy up
and make some soup all right we're
starting with The Usual Suspects garlic
onion
celery
AKA classic mirepoix I'm gonna throw
some big pieces of parsley and Thyme and
I peeled the Mandarin gonna throw that
in there because I think it's gonna add
like a nice you know Southern
Mediterranean flavor
I'm gonna add in a chopped potato
which is going to add lots of fiber
along with the rest of our veg plus it's
going to help to thicken the stew got
some diced tomatoes I got this one with
Italian spices just because like why not
make it easier for myself
and I've got some chicken bone broth
here
adding more protein and of course some
liquid and chicken like Flavor obviously
if you want to make this pescetarian you
can use like a fish based broth but it's
just harder for me to access those most
the time I way to add any
a lot of the moisture is going to come
out of my veg so let's pop
potatoes cooked through before we add in
our fish
okay so I've got some frozen halibut
pieces here that are pretty much thawed
through I'm just adding a little bit of
salt and pepper and then I'm going to
throw them in
get them deep in there so that they can
cook through
and get
flavored by all these delicious looking
juices
bye-bye
oh that is a way to combine fish and
soup in one pot plus we've got fiber
rich carbs protein and fat here and
despite it being a light meal I think
this one's gonna hit the spot
hmm Brody add in the obligatory meme
favorite time of day dessert so I wasn't
to find a lot of information about Marie
Roots other than the fact that she
enjoys dark chocolate in moderation
basically her and every other former
Victoria Secret model but because I have
zero interest in needing a single square
of dark chocolate I thought let's make a
little more fun and make some chocolate
fondue we're gonna do my take on cheater
fondue AKA basically just like a
chocolate dip but I add some peanut
butter in there for extra flavor and
protein and healthy fats we have some
dark chocolate shavings I'm gonna add in
a little coconut cream
where
some peanut butter
Boop
and I'm just gonna throw this into the
microwave at half power for like 30
seconds as I stir in between it smells
so good little fancy salt
we got our chocolate now we need a
Dipper a little shish kebab it's like
the Grinch and I don't even plan for
that this is like something you should
see on Pinterest ah I'm super proud of
me right now moment
now we dip and we
ruined Mr Grinchy I guess we can
actually do it oh yeah oh baby
what else does this need
honestly nothing
and because it's just for me I'm a
double dip so don't come at me
skew team on the way
the best well that was way more fun than
I expected like I watched the entire
hour-long interview on skinny
confidential and let's just say it was a
lot it kind of came across as food
fear-mongering and pseudoscience 101.
basically I interpreted a lot of what
she was saying as everything is poison
everything is causing disease and if
you're not carefully inspecting and
obsessing over every product that you
come into contact with or that comes
into your house you're not taking care
of your health it was actually pretty
triggering to listen to the whole
interview so please do be mindful of
that if you do decide to watch so yeah
not surprisingly I did have to call out
a fair bit of BS here and make some very
liberal adjustments to the meals but
I've really come to expect nothing less
and you guys really should too for every
celebrity diet recall there is out there
there are hundreds if not thousands of
young girls trying to emulate it to a T
and that's pretty useless considering
how unique and different our needs are
but also can be super problematic
considering how restrictive these model
diets are so just reminder to please
never use a wedding a day video or a
diet recall as anything more than some
kind of meal or food inspiration and if
a cilantro seaweed smoothie doesn't
inspire you guys I say move along thanks
again to adoku for sponsoring today's
video you can download the game for my
link in the description and on that note
that is all that I have for you guys
today if you like this video be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below on Whose diet you'd like me to try
next subscribe to the channel and I'll
see you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
foreign
[Music]